mit denen kann man nicht reden warum
nicht das weiß ich nicht das müssen sie
die menschen fragen die da demonstrieren
da ist auch ig metall dabei das ist
jetzt nicht nur schade ja
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier aus der afg
arena in bremen ii kommt es heute zu den
top begegnung der erz rivalen euro hass
gegen asylanten hasser wir sind sehr
gespannt wer das rennen machen wird
die mitglieder der alternative für
deutschland im ehrlichen wettkampf und
es ist auch ein battle der teamcaptains
bernd lucke gegen petri und bauland und
lucke legt aggressiv vor
ich bin wie kein anderes mitglied der
partei das gesicht der partei gewesen
die 15 minute immer wieder werden die
ausländer verstehe in der partei von
schnellen kontern überrascht diebstahl
und einbruch das kann ihn also in allen
teilen der gesellschaft
ob nun von deutschen oder auch von der
eingereisten ausländer passieren also
das würde ich also nicht auf die
waagschale legen es ist also ein
phänomen das wir weltweit
das ist eben völlig normal auto
gestohlen schon in polen
die 75 spielminuten die konfrontation
land ein wenig da ist es gut wenn man
sich auf einen gemeinsamen gegner
einigen kann und das sind natürlich wie
immer die medien erwähnen arbeiten sie
das wird ja auch mein kumpel drauf ist
hätte es ja ich kann ihnen antworten
wenn ich nachher auf den zusammenschnitt
dem sie machen auch einfluss habe vorher
gebe ich ihnen keine antwort aber jetzt
noch mal die frage wie wir heute an die
a f steht der hat von demokratie keine
ahnung die afc ist antidemokratisch aber
das ist die größte schande dass auf den
mitglieder mit peggy das sprechen ich
würde ein großteil der afg
funktionsträger im klassischen sinn als
idioten bezeichnet
doch dann der schock mindestens 20 bis
30.000 hooligans stören diese bislang so
friedlich verlaufende begegnung hat das
noch was mit sport zu tun
ich persönlich hatte schon ausreichend
erfahrungen der antifa gesammelt wenn
leute unter sind sehr viele
hochkriminelle leute dabei und diese
werden von öffentlichen geldern gestützt
und gefördert und das ist unglaublich
woher haben sie dass sie gefördert
werden können sie in jedem bericht lesen
zum beispiel im bildungsetat der
landeshauptstadt schwerin 400.000 euro
für den kampf gegen rechts im
bildungsetat es ist skandalös
ist es was schlechtes gegen rechts zu
kämpfen sie kennt denn wer nur kinect er
kann ja eindeutig nur ganz links in der
ecke stehen oder es kann auch ein ganz
normaler demokrat sein
ich sage ich mit denen kann man nicht
reden
warum nicht das weiß ich nicht das
müssen sie die menschen fragen die da
demonstrieren
da ist auch ig metall dabei das ist
jetzt nicht nur schade wenn diese gegen
deutschland sind wenn sie dieses land
hessen und verachten was bringen sie
auch zum ausdruck dann sind ist das auch
rasten lassen ja nicht deutschland hat
dort half der bundesliga der populisten
diese herberger so schön sagte nach dem
hass angst vor dem hass und damit zurück
ins studio
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag überall dreck
risiken liegen und ihr lastet das xenix
ein beschissenes am boden
[Musik]